皆さんこんにちは今日はお家の展覧会を見に来て下さって誠に有難うございます
今回は私 fires とより大津の展覧会担当
骨組み守ろう合掌集落の好きがお送りいたします
短い時間ではありますがご一緒によろしくお願い致します
今回一緒に見学する大図案
こちらあのユーチューバー肇社長がする
いい
でございますとても奇麗なお家ですねまたリモートでも広いし4部屋が4つほどござい
ますこちらの大広間になるのですがとても広いスペースでこの家に住んでいらっしゃる
金もとても満足しているご様子でございます
隣の部屋に行ってみましょう
[音楽]
こちらが編集する部屋になっております間取りもとても広いですね
パソコンが置いてありこちらにはこたつそしてあてらには
などがありこの窓の国はベランダ等ございます
行ってみましょう
綺麗なベランダですね
これだけ広いとこのベランダでも動画の撮影や洗濯物ほしいなどもできそうですね
さ3つほどお部屋を紹介してきましたが皆様いかがだったでしょうか
デジがただ紹介するだけでなく実際にこの部屋に住んでみないとわからないこと
とっても多いと思いますそこでこの物件に住まわれているはじめ殺王様本人から
コメントを頂いております
[音楽]
なるほどなるほど
隣の部屋との行き来が遠すぎて嫌になる
なるほどなるほどそうですね始めさそうさがこの物件の隣のお部屋も借りて
いらっしゃるようですね
隣の部屋はじめアミューズメントパークに移動する際はまず階段を下り
玄関を出て道を歩いて再び玄関に入る
で廊下歩いて階段を登って初めてはじめニュース面とパーク
本気に作っ
[音楽]
どやあチョンやわーなお分かかるんだよ1個までああ
隣の部屋に住みながら無垢さすがにちょっと多いと思うんだよああ
肇社長ですとなりを感じで結構日が経つんですけども通ってる二階議員のにさんに1回
1回
転換でてまた1回里に帰ってこの中に1玄関玄関12の動きが雷つーわけで私
考えてしまいましたこの移動図鑑を
短縮する方法を準備するものは簡単ですこちらはしごです先ほどの始めたと先ほど外し
たその部屋を部屋の展覧会で見たと思うんですけどもう僕はまだここにいるんですよ
ここにで国家
ブーバー漆器パティニョ
てじゃあ行ってんちょーから15
頭がベランダにはしごをかけたらもう
出てベランダいって軽々にすぐつくわけですよ
時短ですっている実態難病できるわかんないんですけどももしこれで仮ですよ5秒
ショートカット5秒時間短縮できるとしますよそれを365日するだけで30分の時間
短縮が1年でできます30分有意義に過ごせると相当でかいですからこういう時間短縮
が
大事ですよって受けて早速はしごをかけて時間短縮の新しいお家のルートをつくって
いきましょう
ジャイ子よ
母
ああああああああ
ん
これ完璧考える子なんだけどなあと足音をカーブ年でお守りを受けますね
par
大丈夫かなとかっこいいしてねーん
ねっむ高い所入りませんね
それすんの
[音楽]
こんな
感じですでこっちて
橋が乗ってきてここにかけます
ていました
a
tan
ん
ああああああ
ってカッコイッ
はいっ
ています
ber
これでいつも編集している2号室から出ってセグベランダでてあぁ製法を登って来片方
が張って言ってそのままをれるとすぐ始めみう詰めてパークに行くことができます
[音楽]
ございますパンジーたポリだーらーん
の水もにっ
ああああああ
[音楽]
me
を常に持っています
rar
me
ええええええ
[音楽]
me
ええええええ
あっはぁ